vous avez contracté lakovic 19 au début
de l'épidémie une forme assez light
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire j'ai
été très chanceuse et vous trouvez
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un manque de
cohérence vous dites dans ce nouveau
confinement
non je pense qu'il ya eu un manque de en
fait il ya un manque de compréhension
d'accord de moins en mois j'ai
l'impression alors c'est très compliqué
de surtout que ma condition ne
m'autorise pas à venir sur votre terrain
madame mais je effectivement on a tout
entendu les montages sur internet et
sert à nous ont montré le masque palmes
masques on ouvre on ferme nous au
théâtre on a joué cinq fois on a fermé
etc etc
la seule chose donc je pense
qu'effectivement comme le disait
monsieur tout à l'heure il ya plein de
gens et à tous les niveaux qui ne
comprennent pas ce qui se passe depuis
très peu de temps seulement
peut-être peut-être quinze jours trois
semaines enfin les épidémiologistes et
les médecins sont d'accord à partir de
ce moment là on entend tout se signale
le signal c'est de dire stop
mais avant ça à la radio à la télévision
on avait sur un plateau un certain
nombre d'épidémiologistes qui était pas
du tout d'accord donc c'est très
difficile de faire entendre raison aux
enfants aux adultes de dire sortez
sortez pas le médecin à rien le masquage
1 aujourd'hui sous votre contrôle
et puis sous le vôtre il ya un appel à
la solidarité que j'entends extrêmement
bien donc ce serait extrêmement
indélicat de ma part de dire que je ne
comprend pas la situation je la
comprends on est en train de de
d'échapper à la mort par une maladie et
surtout en se confinant en essayant de
faire échapper les silences ses enfants
ses parents ses grands-parents
il n'y a pas de débat ce qu'on entend de
monsieur de madame est évidemment
tragique et c'est évidemment ça nous
tire tous les larmes
on sait à quel point c'est douloureux je
vais vous évidemment pas vous faire part
de ma frustration d'acteurs de ne pas
jouer au théâtre
quand je vois cette dame qui a du mal à
boucler les fins de mois j'ai beaucoup
de chance je fais partie des privilégiés
et je remercie tous les jours le bon
dieu mais je remercie aussi le pays dans
lequel je suis et je ne veux pas faire
du tout de démagogie mais je me rends
compte au travers de tout ce que vous
dites et puis depuis quelques jours qu
effectivement on a beaucoup de chance
cyril de vivre dans ce pays
dans un pays où de temps en temps on
demande même et c'est presque indécent
dalle et hâte de jouer le rôle de nos
parents et je me rends bien compte et on
l'aura l'a voulu à un moment de dire
ne sortez pas les pas voir pape y aller
va pas voir mamie externe à ce que
pourrait presque indigents et c'est
surtout on avait l'impression d'être des
tripes que pour des enfants
aujourd'hui on se rend compte quand même
que l'état fait beaucoup de choses pour
les gens donc c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir une position qui
reste dans le sens dans le mauvais sens
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas dans le sens
du gouvernement
non pas parce que c'est le gouvernement
en place on se fout royalement que ce
soit de gauche de droite ecsta on se dit
juste qu'en ce moment le gouvernement
élu démocratiquement nous a demandé de
faire des efforts au nom de notre
sécurité
j'ai pas l'impression au bout de ces
dernières semaines qu'on nous demande
tout et n'importe quoi et que ils ont
des plans ils font des plans sur la
comète
moi j'ai bien compris malgré
l'incompréhension du départ que ben vous
enseigne pas beaucoup plus que nous et
qu'en fonction des informations que vous
avez des médecins des virologues des
épidémiologistes vous réagissez en ce
sens là on doit vous dire merci et ont
deux se doit et moi j'en appelle à tous
à être effectivement solidaire pour
protéger les nôtres
voilà je pense qu'on aura plein plein de
motifs sur lesquels on va s'engueuler et
ce sera après le confinement
il ya plein de raisons pour lesquelles
on veut ne pas être d'accord avec telle
ou telle disposition
effectivement comme ça spontanément je
vous dirais que plutôt que d'ouvrir les
grandes surfaces j'aurais plutôt ouvert
les petits commerces
je pense que carrefour peut souffrir de
deux mois de fermeture
beaucoup plus qu'un petit commerçant
j'ai ce sentiment là je peux imaginer
que au théâtre les gens regardent droit
devant eux avec des masques et
postillonne pas donc c'est moins
dangereux que de prendre le métro tout
ça j'en conviens mais c'est pas le
moment d'en discuter
il me semble aujourd'hui je trouve que
ce serait indécent où il ya des gens qui
meurent déjà des acquis qui sont en
réanimation au moment où on est en
danger c'est pas le temps de régler nos
comptes
hall et comptons les réglera après par
des voies qui sont d'ailleurs celles du
débat et de la démocratie
mais aujourd'hui je pense en tout cas
moi j'en appelle à tous mes collègues à
la solidarité
voilà michael parce que j'aurais quand
même rebondir sur une chose on a
tendance c'est ce que vous disiez
derrière faut pas opposer les uns aux
autres on a tendance à opposer des
grandes surfaces et les petits
commerçants
mais c'est pas ça la ligne de partage ma
ligne de partage c'est là où on peut
remplir le frigidaire ou des choses
qu'on aime ton maître du mal à se passer
dans la semaine passée les produits de
première nécessité versus là on peut
peut-être attendre deux semaines
ce qui veut pas dire que c'est pas des
produits et
elle c'est ça la différence les rayons
de carrefour qui vendent des chaussures
et des vêtements ils ont été fermés oui
ce qu'ils ont été fermées et la deuxième
chose c'est que quand vous allez manger
avec 80% des français ils ont besoin des
grandes surfaces
et si demain on ferme les grandes
surfaces c'est juste pas alimenter tous
les français devraient dire qu'on fait
c'est pas mon des bahamas non non je
n'en sais rien mais je sais c'est parce
que on a tous des idées ce qui est
extraordinaire je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs c'est notre président qui
avait dit les français ont deux
particularités pente plis pense tout ce
qui pourrait éprouver remet la france et
est sélectionneur de l'équipe de monde
de foot
bon c'est pourquoi il n'avait pas tort
on a tous nos idées sur la question mais
je trouve que c'est pas le moment d'en
parler après quand on va élargir le
débat je peux vous apporter le petit
tout petit peu que je sais dans le
domaine de la culture
pour le reste est obligé de vous dire
qu'on se doit d'être d'accord avec vous
en ce moment en tout cas avec vous et le
gouvernement parce que j'ai bien compris
encore ce soir que jean castex faisait
tout pour essayer de protéger la
population et on doit lui rendre grâce
c'est pas le moment d'appeler à la
désobéissance civile j'ai entendu ici ou
là ces conneries là je ne crois pas que
ce soit le moment il y aura tout le
temps après de s'exprimer quand on n'est
pas d'accord
non